so Donald Trump continues to tweet and
to say more and more about how he is
bringing troops home from Syria and this
has been one of the big defenses and
justifications for what is actually a
completely short-sighted and haphazard
decision to abandon the Kurds in
northern Syria who were immediately
attacked by Kurdish forces after
American troops pulled back we're
bringing troops home has been the story
except it turns out that that is also
not true Trump tweeted that the troops
are coming home and then the Pentagon
Chief Mark Esper said well they're not
really coming home they're going from
Syria to Iraq the troops are actually
going to the epicenter of so-called
endless war in Iraq and when you look at
the details of the entire situation it
is truly in every sense the worst of
American foreign policy and I'll explain
what I mean we abandoned the Kurds in
northern Syria okay so that is a problem
we immediately have the narrative that
getting troops out of anywhere at any
opportunity is by default the right
thing and we should be praising Trump
for it
despite all of the both circumstantial
questions about it foreign policy
questions about it
motivational questions about it
blackmail questions about it in all
sorts of questions around Trump's
decision okay but we're told we are at
least going to get troops out of harm's
way we're going to get out of an endless
commitment that is all good even if it
has some unintended consequences like
the deaths of Kurds except we quietly
kept a small number of forces in
northern Syria anyway not much
publicized what are they doing not
protecting the Kurds they're protecting
oil fields oil fields
case in point prototypical of American
foreign policy abandoned the Kurds
protect the oil fields okay but that's
not bad enough then Mark Esper says in
the same statement where he says a small
number of troops are still there
protecting oil fields he says all US
troops leaving Syria are going to
western Iraq no
is coming home the story is false the
United States is not leaving the region
and it's really important to understand
the significance of this the entire
justification for abandoning the Kurds
opening the door to the resurgence of
Isis that we are now dealing with as the
French Prime Minister recently told us
it was all about stopping endless and
indefinite military commitments getting
out of the region taking our troops out
of harm's way the troops are moving from
Syria to Iraq
we aren't ending indefinite military
commitments we aren't taking those
troops out of harm's way we're not
getting out of the region we're not
doing any of the things that supposedly
are good about the decision to leave
northern Syria and we're actually
perpetuating many of the problems that
some claim Trump is solving by leaving
northern Syria we're shifting troops
around and we're shifting troops around
in a way that has led to Kurds being
killed to the pleasure by the way of
Putin and Iran while not accomplishing
any of the outwardly stated goals this
is a microcosm of foreign policy under
Donald Trump it's a combination of
everything Trump says is actually the
opposite with not accomplishing the
stated goals never properly analyzing
what might actually be a motivating
factor and then in the end we're
actually doing the opposite of what it
is that we claim to be doing via these
foreign policy decisions now you know
the everything Trump says being the
opposite is not new there's many
examples of that in the Trump presidency
Trump says he's going to drain the swamp
he has filled the swamp more than any
president in recent history Trump says
he knows trade and he's going to do
better on trade than anybody else people
fall for it then he starts a trade war
that he can't win and he absolutely
decimates Midwestern farmers in the
United States he says he will end
conflicts of interest with his
businesses he actually has more
conflicts of interest than ever
he's funneling millions of dollars into
his park
by virtue of being president and those
pockets of his friends and family he
will be the most transparent president
with the most transparent administration
no press briefing since is it last March
I mean has it been nearly what seven
eight nine months since the last actual
press briefing and of course bring the
troops home and get them out of harm's
way and get out of an indefinite
conflict in an endless conflict and it's
the opposite it's will send them
elsewhere while our allies who have been
helping us to fight Isis the Kurds are
getting killed if you don't see the
tragedy that this foreign policy and
this presidency is then maybe you
deserve this presidency I'm sort of at a
loss for how to even sum it up but the
exact opposite of what we were told is
happening is actually what is happening
on the ground and you don't have to go
to fake news media to be told it you
just read the words of Trump's own
Pentagon chief mark Esper he's telling
you what's going on